good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this short webinar it's gonna be a first
webinar that we do on this topic of
reputable bioinformatics and the
bio-computer objects and we hope to
continue and do more of these sessions
in the future and incorporate them into
some of our training programs so I
briefly wanted to first of all talk
about why we are doing this and where
this is going so as you can see we have
a bunch of different logos here so we
wanted to start introducing the
bio-computer objects in the context of
the bioinformatics training that we are
conducting with Louisiana biomedical
research network and some were other
partners and universities where we these
programs so we wanted to first of all
introduce Jonathan keaney who's going to
be speaking today from george washington
university and part of the bio-computer
organization and i'll let him talk a
little bit more about that but we also
wanted to use this opportunity to kind
of explore the precision fda
bio computer object a pathan I'm sure
that Jonathan is going to be mentioning
that as well but recently we learned
about this and we wanted to see whether
some of our projects that are in
development some of the research
projects that have been initiated
between the faculty and the students
might be a good fit for this challenge
unfortunately the challenge has only 15
days remaining but as we will see today
this is not as complicated as it might
seem so maybe we will find a good fit
there and so to introduce everybody to
this concept and to the challenge itself
we're going to do the webinar today and
we're also going to try and do another
one maybe at an earlier time so some of
the international participants can join
as well and we will also be recording
this session and then making it
available for anyone that's a part of
our project
so now I just wanted to introduce
introduce Jonathan Keaney Jonathan and
teeny is part of the executive steering
committee for the bio compute and he's
also an assistant research professor at
the George Washington University so he's
going to be speaking about the
bio-computer project and giving us a
little hands-on tutorial some of you
might want to participate in trying to
replicate this yourselves but of course
there are some registration aspects that
we might not be able to complete but at
least you'll get a glimpse of what this
is and realize how important this might
be to make our bioinformatics projects
more reproducible and ultimately in the
future leading to the FDA and regulation
being a big part of this as well so I'll
turn it on turn it over to Jonathan
Jonathan if you can try and mute
yourself so we can check that everything
is working okay well thank you very much
for the introduction we can probably do
a little probably not too much hands-on
I think as William mentioned there is
kind of a sign up steps so we can try to
get going on that as much as possible
and I'm happy to stay on and help out
anyone who does want to try it out but
I'll at least show you to where that is
and show you how you can use some of the
tools that we've developed to try and
work with a biome the bio computes and
'red so I'll talk about this in they
have a very high level for starting from
a very high level and kind of narrow it
down assuming that nobody knows anything
about it so just from a very high level
the the the sort of punch line was bio
computers that it's a way to collect and
communicate all of the details of a
bioinformatics workflow so if you were
go get your genome sequence you would
get maybe hundreds of millions of raw
reads these are all a TCG and so forth
and those are meaningless to a human so
in order to be able to turn that into do
anything meaningful like ancestry or
cancer or microbiome disease correlation
things like that there's the certain
number of transformation data
transformation steps that have to happen
sometimes an extraordinary number the
number of steps and Pharma can sometimes
exceed 100 and right now it's kind of a
black box because everyone is this is
very much an exploratory phase and
that's wonderful and we're all learning
a lot but when it comes to having to
communicate that from one place to
another for a variety of reasons it
becomes very difficult and so oftentimes
what happens is a bioinformatician and
their team might work on the data for
maybe six to eight months kind of trying
things out seeing what works trying
other things if it doesn't and by the
end of all that the original architect
of the pipeline understands what
happened and the entire pipeline is very
clear to them but it's not clear to
anyone else and it's sometimes not
reproducible and so this is very similar
to what you might see in a wet lab
experiment there are certain inputs that
need to be reported with with the
experiment in order to make sense of it
so you couldn't just be given a
fluorescent microscope microscope slide
for example and necessarily know all of
the details about it
you need things like strain of the
animal what's the tissue type that
you're looking at some of the more
granular details like a protein lot
number if you're doing a fluorescence in
situ experiment things like that that
are not you can't Intuit those kinds of
details if you want to be able to repeat
the experiment and bioinformatics is no
different there's there's a number of
inputs and parameters that are needed to
be able to reproduce or in some most
cases even understand a bioinformatics
pipeline and so this has been a real
challenge not just for folks that are
new to bio informatics but even for
experienced eye informaticians because
it's oftentimes not clear what all needs
to be communicated and so one of the
biggest places it's been felt is in
academic publishing there's been
replication crisis going on in terms of
being able to reproduce experiments and
I think many of us are aware of that but
another one of the major places where
it's been very problematic is in
submissions to the FDA so oftentimes
what happens in submission to the FDA as
an industry sponsor will submit some
data and that if that includes any sort
of bioinformatic pipeline the FDA will
review it usually what happens is
they'll have to kick it back to the
industry sponsor with need for
clarification or issues or questions or
something something along those lines
excuse me and the industry sponsor will
then have to figure out what it was that
the FDA didn't understand because this
is not a situation where you can sit
down next to someone at a computer and
just sort of walk them through what you
did every time this data changes hands
it goes through lots of attorneys and so
this can add months and months of time
and millions of dollars was at one point
estimated maybe six million dollars for
one of these the industry sponsor then
tries to address those things and
resubmit in fact there's actually sort
of a funny anecdote about this at one
point an industry sponsor submitted this
to this the FDA I in question in this
particular case reached out and said I
have a question about this bioinformatic
pipeline what did you do here or what
did this mean and they said we don't
know the post
sooner a postdoc leave
needless to say that that application
did not was not approved so the industry
sponsor will then resubmit and sometimes
they can go around this loop many many
times adding even more time and even
more cost to it before the FDA finally
just has enough to be able to make a
decision and this is a really really big
problem because the FDA recognizes the
power in precision medicine and the fact
that bioinformatics analyses at
particular NGS or HTS as we're saying
high throughput sequencing data can be
for precision medicine it's it's really
helping to power a lot of this but when
it comes to actually getting approval
for these things it's very problematic
because it's it's taking up the time and
it's taking up the money but it's in no
way improving the probability of getting
an approval decision and so essentially
all it's doing is increasing the risk
for one of these and that's a really big
problem so it's a big problem that kind
of needs to be addressed and the way
that it's traditionally been handled as
each individual reviewer will put it the
put out their own document that sort of
explains you know if you're planning to
submit NGS data to us here's what I
recommend you do these are not
standardized documents as you can see
here it's not an official guidance
document this is just the opinion of one
reviewer and it's based on their
experience so it's very much trial and
error sort of how they've figured out
from these these these situations where
it didn't work what sorts of things you
can do and so it's very piecemeal and
it's not standardized across the FDA
it's not even standardized across
centers at the FDA it's very much sort
of ad hoc and it makes it very difficult
to be able to predict what the FDA wants
in terms of this data and it's it's it's
been a challenge way frankly because
it's new enough that I think the FDA has
not been able to say what they want from
the data so there's been a very big
drive to try and address that and so the
FDA convened a special session special
session of the genomics working group
and this is a working group at the FDA
that has broad expertise in genomics
across lots of different fields and
across all the different centers today
representation FDA wide and so in 2013
that convened a special session to
address this
and that working group came up with this
bulleted list for what any sort of
solution should have these are the four
bullets it should be human readable sort
of like a GenBank sequence record if
you're familiar with that it's just a
name value pair or key value pairs they
say it should be computer readable
meaning any data that's in there should
be structured and adhere to that
structure in some very predictable way
so that you can work with that data if
you need to it should contain enough
information to understand the
computational pipelines interpret that
information maintain records and
reproduce experiments that's really the
core of the entire concept and then
finally there should be some way to make
sure that the information has not been
altered so once you build a record in
whatever way this is it has to be
immutable if you do anything to change
it then it's it's no longer the same
thing so the solution to that is what we
now call bio compute so this began as a
collaboration between George Washington
University and the FDA it's a standard
well it's a forthcoming standard rather
for communicating genomic analysis
workflows and this should really take
bioinformatic workflows in fact it the
heart and soul was born with genomic
analysis workflows but it's it's really
very well adapted to any bioinformatic
pipeline at this point we've tried quite
a few others including building
databases for example it acts like an
envelope for an entire pipeline which
means that it can incorporate several
other standards that includes cwl or
Whittle if you're using either of those
so that that would be good for
portability of execution for example
particularly if you're using command
line fire genomics is another example so
that's fast healthcare interoperability
resources that's good if you're working
with patient data for example and you
are building apps on a mobile phone or a
tablet or something like that
so a much more kind of clinical and
applied side so it works very well with
all these other standards cc2 is another
example ga4gh so it's built with the FDA
both with input from FDA personnel in
terms of what their needs are and with
FDA funding initially we recently just
received a grant
our training some more of the FDA folks
as a matter of fact and gaining even
more use case scenarios and we have a
publication that is well I should say
manuscript in preparation right now that
is kind of walking through a mock
submission using the bio compute process
it was written to be human and machine
readable so it's written in JSON which
is JavaScript object notation and I'll
show you an example of what that looks
like in case you're not familiar with
that but it's a very simple easy to use
language it's not a programming language
per se it's just a way of structuring
data it's categorized by domains at the
top level so these are sort of ways to
conceptually break down a workflow in
ways that make a lot of sense so if you
were interested in the metadata there's
a place to look for that if you're
interested in the the parameters that
were used to actually run the steps
there's a place for that and so forth
and I'll show you an example of these
things it adheres to the fare principle
so it's findable accessible
interoperable and reusable each of the
letters in that acronym has a very
specific meaning that a pretty large
international community has agreed upon
and we've got a few representatives that
have been part of the bio-computer
consortium that have been very strong
advocates for that so so bio compute
does conform to the fare principles it's
very adaptable it's got an execution
domain in it as well sorry not an
execution to main an extension domain
and so the extension domain is a
user-defined domain that allows the user
to tie it to any other schema that
they'd like or any other resource so
that makes it very adaptable it
preserves data provenance there's
actually an entire domain the provenance
domain that lets you track who transform
that data and it's also got an embargo
field and a sort of a time time valid on
it so sort of like at an expiration date
on it if you need to do either of those
things as well the provenance I mean in
particular has been very appealing for
certain groups one startup as a matter
of fact based in Boston who is trying to
kind of transform the way that
individuals
will contribute their genomes so instead
of getting your your your genetic data
from a 23andme or in ancestry.com or
something like that and checking the box
that says yes I would like to
participate in research at which point
they take that data essentially in
perpetuity and sell it when and however
they'd like the goal of this particular
startup is to create an online
marketplace where individuals have
retained rights over their data so
someone if say a biotech company gets
onto the marketplace and searches for
white males between the ages of x and y
and my my profile shows up they can make
an offer to use my genetic data in their
clinical trials and I have the option to
say yes or no and so this is kind of
nice because it keeps the incentive for
individuals to continue volunteering
their data there's their personal
genetic data for that reason but it does
so without stripping them of the rights
of that data in the future so I think
it's really exciting and they're they're
using bio compute as a framework for
their entire marketplace because
primarily of that provenance domain so
it you you always have a clear record of
what was done with that data and by whom
and when so it keeps everything very
transparent and finally it has unique
IDs for versioning and so this was how
the problem of being immutable was
solved and so the unique IDs there's
there's a registry where you can
register your domain and then you're
your own organization can kind of
determine what the value for that unique
ID is but if anything changes then then
the unique ID has to change so we have a
registry that lets you do that and a an
aggregator that kind of compares them so
so once you build a record which is
called a bio compute object or bco so
it's a specific instance of a pipeline
written in bio compute then it gets its
own unique ID and that's it so if you
change anything then you then have to
version the unique ID and so a good
analogy for this but I like to give
because there has been a little bit of
confusion over what exactly the standard
is standardizing a good analogy for this
is Wi-Fi which is wireless internet
that's more formally known as the 802
dot one one
because they went through the I Triple E
standardization process Institute for
electrical and electronic engineers and
so Wi-Fi is a good analogy for this
because Wi-Fi does not standardize
whatever product you're making you know
if you make a Mac or a PC or a printer
or toaster or whatever you make all you
have to do is configure that device to
use or rather to be compliant with the
a/o 2.11 standard and they don't try to
standard a standardized the platform
that you use it could be Mac or Windows
or FaceTime or whatever they don't
standardize the data that you're using
or the apps that you're using on the on
the computer you know the only things
they're standardizing is the way that
that information is collected and
reported between two entities and so
that's that's a very good analogy for
bio-computer you can use any platform
that you want you can use any sequence
or you can use any bioinformatics tools
or pipeline that you like you can
develop your own pipeline that's all
fine this is just a way of collecting
and communicating that information back
and forth between two entities and so
this could be the FDA in a pharma
company for example instead of a router
and a Mac okay so that's a brief
introduction to it so this is sort of a
crushed down snapshot of what a bco
would look like so it's color-coded
just for clarity here so the top section
is all metadata
it's all written in JSON which as I said
is just key value pairs so ID
what's the ID name what's the name
there's no logic in JSON it's not
there's no if then else or for loops or
anything like that it's as I said it's
really just a way of organizing the data
it includes a usability domain which is
just in plain language what did I do and
what was I hoping to find in this sort
of an executive summary of the entire
pipeline this is also where you can
include details about about the pipeline
itself since this is metadata so for
example if you ran a pipeline for one
specific purpose but you just want to
include a note in there that says if you
wanted to use this for this sort of
similar related purpose might consider
changing step four into XY and Z this
would be the place to do that
there's
so a description domain which includes
keywords and cross-references if
necessary and pipeline steps I'll show
you an example of those the execution
domain is a platform that it was run on
and that has to include things like the
any drivers and scripts and other
prerequisites that are necessary to
execute that anything necessary for
deployment essentially along with the
versions and ways to access to them
parametric domain is a record of all the
parameters that went in and this is
specifically just the parameters that
were changed so anything that's not
default so for example if you're running
a pipeline at the command line a lot of
these command line tools have default
options built-in so if you change any of
those options this is where you would
record that but anything that you don't
change does not need to be recorded and
so each each each tool will have its own
specific set of parameters that can be
changed and a different number of them
and many of them therefore will not have
anything that's changed after that is
the i/o domain which is the input/output
list and so this is just a list of files
rather it's a list of where you can
access those files in the form of a URI
we don't actually keep any of the data
on board with a VCO these are just
references or pointers to where those
files live so the final file size of a
bco is on the order of kilobytes but we
still do to include a record of where
those where those files are and then
finally the error domain and so this
would be where you keep information like
both discovery rate other other metrics
that you might have benchmarked your
pipeline for that you can kind of use to
sort of demarcate the bounds of the
pipeline so what's the minimum read
quality that your pipeline is able to
work with what's the minimum reap depth
for example and so the i/o domain and
the error domain are collectively what
we're calling the verification kit which
means given some input file or files and
given this error domain is the output
domain valid and so that is sort of a
quick control test that can be run to
make sure that anything that's being
submitted along with this pipeline
actually
is valid it should in fact be detectable
by this type line so that's essentially
what the the pipeline is right now we're
currently working with 1.3 version 1.3
and this is a link to that this is all
on github the 1.4 version is very close
this is going to write Triple E
standardization right now and it's
already test the the major boat and it's
already gone through commenting so it's
passed the valid its best the comment
saying it's currently in comment
resolution and very nearly complete so I
expect this to be submitted to the
formal I Triple E voting process at the
end of this year and so probably early
2020 I would expect 1.4 to be live and
to hopefully be and I Triple E certified
standard so sort of let's see are you
able to see this screen now the browser
screen no we actually still see your
presentation okay let me switch over to
this right here ya know now I can see
your screen okay great
so this is the so the the 1.4 is now
being kept on get lab there's been some
changes with this one and so we've got a
different kind of an organization for
each of these domains here so each
top-level domain has its own
specification here that's referenced by
the main which is about computer object
JSON currently and so one of the big
changes is that we are building the
entire thing onto JSON schema so we
inherit all of those automatically and
one of the sort of big upgrades I guess
that we get from that is the ability to
include the required an optional and
that's not present in the 1.3 and so in
the main file you can see the the oldies
domains that I talked about the
top-level domains that are sort of the
conceptual breakdown are required and
then in addition to that there's three
that are required the BC ood which is
the unique
i D of the of the BCO the spec version
which in this case will be 1.4 and then
it checks some which we're using sha-256
for so then each of these different
domains has separate dependencies
therein so here's the the description
domain and you can scroll down and see
this is where the cross references the
space where the cross references are on
the properties access time etc this is
the platform as I mentioned all the
pipeline steps would then come under
here along with the descriptions and the
access times in the URI so this is this
is the current version that 1.4 that I
think is very close and so we can run
conformance checking against these these
schemas until I encourage you to go take
a look at these if you have an interest
as I said we're still currently on the
1.3 which is let me switch back to this
here okay
we are still currently on the 1.3 which
is still functional and in fact is the
one that at least at the moment still
has a manuscript being written about but
I expect 1.4 to be coming out soon and
so there's a couple of groups that have
already started taking a look at that to
see how they can work that into their
workflows there we go
yeah so just for a very quick example we
can just build a quick kind of pipeline
and step through what it would look like
so for example if you're a researcher
and you've got a cohort of individuals
that have HCV one hepatitis C and
they're all in this drug but if it's
beer and there's a subgroup a sub
population there that's a drug resistant
you'd like to explore that and see if
maybe they maybe the virus has acquired
some sort of mutation so that's the
working
Pappas's so you are able to isolate some
of the virus from this drug-resistant
cohort and sequences and so that's what
you've got to start with and so we can
just build a simple two-step pipeline to
investigate that in this case I'm just
showing you an example on the hive
platform the high platform is the major
biomimetics platform that the FDA uses
it's in fact it's the only one aside
from command line that they have
available in inside the firewall we
happen to have a clone of that here at
GW so we're able to build them our own
tools so this example is high but you
know as I said earlier it's platform
agnostic you can do it on any platform
you want this particular tool that we're
using is hexagonal liner and it is
pretty straightforward you input
parameters you can watch the progress
and then look at the results and so
that's the screen run now see that
everything worked out pretty well
there's a pie chart breakdown of
everything so that's fine next step
would be to look for variants with a
goal trying to find any variants that
are consistent only in these drug
resistant individuals but which are not
present in the reference because those
would be a strong candidate for being
causal variance and so this tool is
called the heptagon which uses a VCF or
a variant call file and very similarly
in entered all the parameters watch the
progress seeing the results and so in
this particular case they found what
they were looking for and so we're
zoomed in on this window where you can
see this high degree of variability here
are variants rather and so this is a
pretty interesting case of a potential
precision medicine usage and so any
individual that has HD v1 if they get
the virus sequence and they have this
mutation might not be a very good
candidate for Latifa sphere and so they
of course need to be some follow up to
investigate that but this is a nice
example of of exactly that so building
VCO is sort of like building a recipe
card if somebody else wanted to do this
so if you went to somebody's house and
had this really wonderful salmon and you
wanted to repeat it and you went home
and repeated it was nothing like what
you tried and they said well where did
you get the salmon from and
where did you get your ingredients from
and where did you get the spices from
and things like that there's an example
that one of the FDA folks use and I
liked it so much and trying to repeat it
and hopefully only mildly butchering it
but I think it does a really good job of
kind of getting to why it's sort of at
the top level it may not seem as
necessary because you just sort of write
down the steps but in reality there's a
lot of granularity that goes into each
of these steps and so what you would do
in the case of hive is record all of
these scripts and drivers and
prerequisites for each of the steps
along with any relevant parameters and
include all of that along with the
execution domain which is the platform
that it was run on it so in this case
that was high so you'd have a full step
in both the parametric domain and
description domain for the hexagon and
then for the heptagon you would then add
in pointers to the input and output
domains and have timestamps on all of
these things and then layer on any
necessary usability domain and keywords
and so forth and then if necessary also
an extension domain here that describes
in this case a github URI so if you want
to make elements of this or the entire
pipeline available on github you can do
that as well
and so then you've got this this VCO
that can be shared very easily with
other researchers or with a publication
if you want to publish it or with the
FDA if you want to submit it as part of
a clinical trial and so that's a simple
two-step pipeline you can imagine this
could be used with any number of steps
in fact the more steps there are the
more useful to be CEO actually is if
you're to actually open up one of these
bcos and look inside what you would see
is still relatively easy to read even if
you don't have a text parser so this is
a usability domain this is just in plain
English so wanted to identify baseline
single nucleotide polymorphisms etc so
just the entire experimental procedure
that I explained earlier the pipeline
steps then start to layout each of those
steps so the first one was the high
Tech's agon the description of that is
just to align alignment of reads to a
set of references which version was used
an array of
prerequisites in this case there was
multiple prerequisites so they wanted to
use the hepatitis C virus genotype 1 as
a reference to do the alignment so that
comes in as a prerequisite there's a URI
for where they address that in an access
time in this particular case they felt
they wanted to use the HCV type 1b
complete genome as well so that also
gets listed here any of the
prerequisites that were necessary for
any of the steps would then get listed
in this section here the pipeline steps
in the description domain execution
domain then has all that information
about the platform so again this one was
called hive there's information about
the the version the prerequisites here
again along with all of the URIs and
access times and so forth the parametric
domain so in this case there was only 3
parameters that needed to be included
for hexagon C minimum match length
diversions and then 2 for the high pepti
GaN this is also where you would include
any command-line arguments that were
necessary to invoke the command so - H
or - a or use strict or whatever it is
that you use those kinds of things would
go here and then the i/o domain at the
very end so we've already started
integrating this into a few different
platforms it's on seven bridges and the
cancer genomics cloud or CGC
they have that integrated so there's a
record bio compute button that lets you
do export all the the stuff that can be
exported relatively easily you still
have to fill out some of the metadata
like the usability domain and so forth
and who you are and things like that
well you can automate most of it since
it's in a JSON which is sort of the
lingua franca of all programming
languages we've also got it into hive
there's a record bio compute button
there we are currently working on a
grant to get it integrated into galaxy
so there'll be a nice record bio compute
button built into that sort of doing it
in two approaches there's a tool shed
version and one that's integrated into
the main code and then hopefully soon
get one on DNAnexus as well
and precision FDA which is powered by
DNAnexus so these are platforms that
already have the ability to build
bio-computer objects on them already
which makes it very easy so once you're
done you just export the whole thing and
then add in any relevant details that
you want some of them are also currently
working on readability so you can import
a bio-computer object and have it have
those details ready to go and then
execute portability would be our next
step kind of looking down the road so
you could not only import a BCO but then
have the ability to execute that entire
BCO right off the bat and so we're
working with groups like the association
of pathology chairs for example one of
their sort of subgroups called the goal
consortium is interested in
standardizing the way that cancer is
diagnosed using these NGS platforms and
so every cancer of course is going to
have its own set of needs but the
they'll all in theory have a course set
that they're interested in so maybe
wrasse mutations for example would be on
that that core set and they've got in
fact I think a few hundred genes that
are part of that core set and so we're
working with them to try and build a bco
record of every iteration that they're
building to try out and then have a bco
record of the final version that can be
shared with all the pathology labs
around the United States so if you're
not working on one of those platforms
that has it or you're just working at
the command line we also have a
form-based editor and so this is a way
of trying to make it easier to build a
VCO without actually having to code the
JSON yourself we do actually preserve
the ability to work with JSON so there's
this edit JSON button so you can click
that and open up the JSON and either for
the entire thing or by domain and so the
URL for that is here it's ww-why Oh
compute object org slash VCO underscore
editor underscore TST and so this is
what you can go to today if you would
like you'll need to go to register and I
can activate your account as soon as I
see any of those come in and so you can
take your favorite pipeline or you can
take
publication if you'd like and start to
build a VCO out of it you can save your
changes here as you're working on it and
then come back to it later if you'd like
the only thing I will caution you on is
don't hit the back button or try to
close the tab or anything without saving
it because then you'll lose all of your
work but you can save the changes and
then come back and edit it later or
download it if you'd like to to do
whatever you'd like with so these are
some of the groups that we've worked
with we've worked with a number of
groups in both the public and private
sectors and in academia I haven't put
everyone up here but I tried to put some
of the bigger names and I won't go
through all these I will mention really
quickly though Google because we will
begin working with them so they've
agreed to use the bio compute standard
to host all the strides data or I should
say close all the data as part of the
strides program so that's the NIH
program to make all publicly funded data
available and so they're doing that
through both Google cloud and through
Amazon Web Services and so Google has
agreed to make all this data bio compute
accessible bio computing pine we also
recently had a workshop at the FDA and
so at this workshop we had a discussion
panel with the genomics working group
that originally came up with the idea to
do something along these lines and so
they talked about how workflow
communication is currently being handled
at the FDA and what some of the
challenges are with that and so we had
FDA reviewers FDA researchers some
academia folks some folks from private
sector and one patient advocacy
representative on that discussion pan on
that I think really was the highlight of
the entire workshop it was really good
and there are recordings of that as well
there are there were use case examples I
can go or just a couple of those very
quickly there were ten mohs and hands-on
mostly for the things that I shows you
the seven bridges and the bio computed
etre so demos and hands-on for those
things and then finally a bio compute
challenge on precision FDA which Elia
mentioned and which hopefully some folks
here can contribute to so
at the end of this weekend as I said you
can go to the bio compute editor and and
get started working on it if there's a
pipeline that you would like to record
as a VCO it would be really cool if you
submitted it to the bio-computer on
precision fda that'll get reviewed and
possibly even have a chance to become
part of a publication we're kind of
exploring the idea of doing that and any
publication of course would have to go
through the normal peer-review steps but
what we'd like to do is try to get the
pure the top performers to participate
on a manuscript around this so that's
what we would like to do so if you have
any interest in using this I think
that's probably the fastest way is to
just jump in and start building a
bio-computer object and then submit it
to the the precision fda bio-computer
any anything that you do submit needs to
be in the public domain or you need to
be okay with it being visible by the
public because this is a public website
so please don't put anything up there
that is patent protected or that you're
not able to show to the public for any
reason so some of the use case examples
that were presented at that workshop or
tuberculosis detection so TB is a top
infectious killer in the world and the
whu-oh has adopted the receipt TB
pipeline which is a great pipeline for
this but it still has some of its own
challenges which involves things like
lineage identification prediction of
antibiotic disease recurrence and so
forth and so they're exploring bio
compute to try and help navigate some of
these challenges and in particular the
provenance domain seems to be very
helpful so they gave a talk about using
bio compute for their efforts we had a
test submission this one was with HTV
one a coincidentally this was not the
the example I showed you earlier but
this was the the mock submission where
we worked with a bio informatics company
and with an FDA reviewer and with
guidance from the FDA reviewer came up
with a mock data set we gave it to the
bioinformatics company who ran it
through their actual pipeline and we
used that as a benchmarking since we
came up with the data we know what truth
is so to speak and they ran it to their
pipe
and generate a report and then we were
able to use that as a verification kit
and run an actual mock using a larger
synthetic data set to submit to this FDA
reviewer who then wrote up a full report
of details his his understanding of it
based on the bio-computer in the
bio-computer loans or the BCO I should
say about to be project and the B Jo
alone and then at the same time also
tried to generate his own be Co you
using that data and so that that was a
really cool really exciting one and so
that's that's in preparation right now
and then the last one is in blima which
is a startup that i mentioned earlier
that's building an online marketplace
for buying and selling personal genome
data we are currently going through I
Triple E as I mentioned earlier our
working group and so I Triple E is the
Institute for Electrical and Electronics
Engineers it's a very large
standardization body our sponsor
societies the EMB the engineering and
medicine and biology and our working
group is p2 791 if you have any interest
on in watching the progress on this
we're hoping that the final one
submitted in time for the last voting of
would the last deadline of the year
which i think is december 3rd so we
still got a couple of months before we
need to get that in but i think we're
already ahead of the game because I
think it's very nearly ready
so we've already gone through it's
already passed the ballot and it's
already gone through public review and
so now as I said it can comment review a
comment resolution group or crg and so
it's very nearly finished with that as
well so this will be our 1.4 version
which would be the first to be passed by
I Triple E at the same time we're also
hoping to go through the international
standards organization or ISO that would
give us additional stability it really
would give us additional reach I think
there's it's an even larger society than
I Triple E and so I Triple E and ISO
actually have a joint joint agreement in
place whereby anything that the I Triple
E accepts and publishes as their
standard the ISO has the ability to
publish
sort of as a joint standard and so we've
been exploring that with the SC 32 WG 2
working group at ISO which is convened
by Denise where's L at NCI and so she's
been a observer in our Comment
resolution group at I Triple E as well
so she's keeping tabs on the progress
there we've also recently launched a
public-private partnership this is a way
of sort of bringing in anyone in public
or private or anywhere that has any
interest in weighing in on the bio
compute standard in the way that it's
built in the way that it's used and so
forth and so we recently signed with
Sieber at the FDA the Center for
biologics and what is it Center for
biologics and I'm blanking on the name
right now evaluation in review so so
they've signed a public-private
partnership we will start bringing on
other partners as well very soon now
once the executive steering committee
finalizes a plan for that and so the
primary goal of this public-private
partnership is very much complementary
to all the standardization efforts that
I Triple E and ISO which is to develop a
community of stakeholders with interests
in this area to facilitate the
development of tools and facilities for
use in coordination with bio-computer
and to facilitate the portability of
pipelines for execution and so it's
guided by an executive steering
committee chaired by Rajat Mazumdar
and I'm acting as the managing director
these are the other members of the
committee there's a technical steering
committee just chaired by Headley King
also at GW with some incredibly talented
people from internet2 and NCI and FDA
and galaxy and common workflow language
and several others and this is really I
think the heart and soul of Bayeux
compute so these are the guys that
really really understand the technical
aspects of it and the need for it and
how it can be built and used and so they
they'll help actually building tools and
help out with some guidance in terms of
implementing it as well
so right so this is the the editor I was
talking about if you have any interest
please go to bio-computer object org
slash VCO underscore editor underscore
test and fill out this registration and
I will activate you as soon as as I get
that that notification and then you can
start to build VCO objects on there as
soon as you're ready and then once
you're done with it download it and as I
said if you can go to a bio compute
object a pecan which is the VCO
challenge on precision FDA there's
actually two tracks here there's a
beginner track and an advanced track so
if you are a little bit more than the
technical side we also have this
advantage side which is to submit a
conformance tool and a writer tool
so this conformance to will will check
any bco against the specification and
the writer tool is something that will
have the ability sorry Jonathan you may
be paste the link in chat right here or
maybe go back to that previous line real
quick yeah this so you're talking about
the on-site
no I'm talking about the bio compute
where you oh yeah that one yeah there
you go so anyway you could just paste
that and chat for everyone or oh yeah
yeah sure get out of there where is
there we go so see where is we get to
chat
okay let me pause sharing all right yeah
yeah I didn't do it for you come on okay
it's in there oh you already got okay
sorry about that
okay all right so are you on the are you
seeing this webpage now yeah I'll
compute editor 1.4 you have to log in or
the registration right so you mentioned
that people will submit their name and
then once they click on register you are
the one that gets that yep so we'll
we'll get it here and I can I mean I'll
be here at the computer so I can start
activating people immediately and so all
you'll do is go to create object on the
top right there and then I'll pop up
this example for you that you can work
from if you'd like and then it'll take
you directly to this editor here this is
where you can start inputting all of
your information if you'd like if you
want to include a license you can
include that here and then for each each
portion of this you can add an item if
you need to so for example in parametric
domain if you've got item 1 and you fill
this out and you want to add another one
you can just add that right there and
there's later too
or delete it and again you can always go
to edit JSON and just edit that directly
if you'd like now when you're done just
come up you can come up and just save
the entire thing and then download it if
you'd like so here's Save Changes and
then back at the list you can download
the entire thing as a JSON or you can
always just go to edit JSON here and
copy the entire thing and paste that as
well so there's two different ways to do
it so that is the basics for that and
like in fact - oops yeah so and then the
very last link that I'll share is the a
Pathan site so this is precision fda.gov
slice challenges slash seven and this is
part of the office of the chief
scientist office of health informatics
under Elaine Johansson so that is by Oh
compute and the precision FDA challenge
in a nutshell and I'm happy to hang out
here and kind of help anyone who does
want to walk through that but for now
I'm also happy to take questions yeah
Thank You Jonathan and I just want want
to add to that that what we want to do
is try and work through some of the
projects that are ongoing that we've had
in different programs and hopefully work
through some of these examples that we
have and try to admit them so if you are
a little bit lost as to how to use this
you know we'll reach out with another
time that we could schedule one of these
webinars and kind of do this together
and of course those of you that are
already working on you know different
bioinformatics pipelines and projects I
think there's a way to register yourself
again we have that link on the chat and
right now if there are any questions we
can try and answer those I'm sure
Jonathan can have any input and you know
whatever you're working on hi John this
is protein can I ask you questions I
have yeah sure go ahead yeah so oh one
of the thing was that you know you
talked about the JSON objects which are
meta data exchange format so you already
have defined objects in the JSON schema
is it possible to create new objects
which may be useful for a specific
project or something like that yeah
using using fields that are not already
defined is that the question yes
something like that exactly on that line
yep so there is an extension domain and
that's as I said that's sort of like a
user-defined field so we we kind of
leave that one open it doesn't have any
it really any rigid
kind of guidance on that one oh but we
have kind of recommended as the best
practice is that you build your own
schema of any kind and then include a
URI to that in in the extension domain
so that's the way that we can validate
against that most easily is if there's
just a URI in that field okay thank you
very much and one other question I had
let's say you know I have you showed us
a few examples specifically on this HCB
one and there was not one cancer I
presume I've got I mean let's say there
are two therapeutic areas let's say one
is a cancer one is an infection so is it
possible that you know both of the same
book the same you know the same busy
objects are kind of used for both the
therapeutic areas or both you know both
the same the same problem sharing common
Bissell's
is it is it kind of thing that might
occur yeah well so I think that that is
kind of the goal with the
standardization of cancers
you know the diagnosis of human cancers
that's that's sort of the goal sharing
across different areas is yeah it's
certainly possible I think it's less
likely you know when you do sequencing
of viruses for example versus humans you
might have a different seed size and
minimum match links and things like that
so some of the details there kind of you
know my intuition is that it's unlikely
that those would be shared across
regions that far but we do certainly
expect that some of these are going to
be very much standardized and as we
begin to figure out which pipelines work
the best there will be sort of a natural
demand for those ones and there will be
sort of a natural demand for
authenticity of those pipelines you know
so there's got to be some way to get it
and have a lot of confidence that what
you've gotten is authentic and has not
been tampered with
and so by Oh compute kind of has a very
natural way to help facilitate that so
you can have authenticity kind of built
in there and we have an aggregator that
lets you compare a hash against like an
sha-256 for example so yeah we are very
much expecting that there are going to
be some
instances where there's sort of a high
demand for a be CEO that's used in more
than one instance I'm an overlap between
the two things over Oh
overlap between like let's say
infectious disease and cancer yeah yeah
yeah so again I I don't know it I guess
it would just kind of come down to the
specifics I certainly don't want to say
that it's impossible that something like
that would happen my limited experience
going looking at B cos in those two
different realms as I say my intuition
is that the the needs of each of those
pipelines tend to be different but I can
certainly imagine that that it could
happen is very useful in both of those
areas yeah thank you very much we so
that actually came up during the
discussions that we had back during the
working group and unfortunately the
security hatches is not really my area
of expertise but there was a couple of
folks who have worked on projects like
this and they felt reasonably confident
that using a hash was a pretty pretty
good way to go with it
you know we it has not formally passed
the finish line yet so if you felt for
some reason there's a really strong
reason that we shouldn't use that then I
would certainly welcome you to submit
that issue on get lab and suggest
something alternatively do you think
that a digital signature would be
stronger than a hash
with oh just straight somebody or and so
the rainbow tables basically like a
database of plaintext to the hash codes
you know if you will end up with
children baby six that's right now
that's actually quite large it might be
infeasible to construct a rainbow table
that size it's quite a large yeah but in
the future it may turn out to be the
case that particular sha-256 I'm not
saying that there are weaknesses now but
there may be discovered and the nice
thing about the digital signature is is
that don't only get the integrity I'll
also get computing H so that you can say
that this entity was actually
responsible for providing this fireball
that's something worth considering yeah
yeah well I know that uh there was new
that I guess it was Google has released
a or not released but developed the
first quantum computer right so maybe
it's time to start thinking about things
that are not hash based right the
strings like that right so that that's a
fair point we do have the initial so
there's a registry that lets you kind of
establish a domain so for example we
would be gwu which would kind of prepend
our our unique ID fda could come up with
airs so you can go register a domain
just like as if you were go daddy or or
even you know do is for example digital
object identifiers and that kind of that
sort of authenticates where it comes
from and then we've got the aggregator
which mirrors any of these that are
built and so that's that's sort of
another check so that we can you can
authenticate against that and so you
know that this says that it came from
such-and-such and this is the security
on it and and all of that seems to match
what's on the aggregator so we have some
of that in place yeah I think
I think it's a pretty good system and
the framework for that is very nearly
deployed thank you
sure thank you all right well thank you
Jonathan for this presentation and for
what you've shared again we're gonna
have a recording of this session where
we'll make it available to everybody
that participated or that wanted to
participate and we'll try and hold again
another webinar Jonathan whenever your
schedule permits with some of the people
that couldn't make it
during this later time and also try to
work independently with the different
groups that we have to start submitting
some of these viral compute projects or
objects and try it out and see how it
works so thank you everyone that joins
and we hope to see this once again maybe
in more detail on how to practically do
this next time Thank You Jonathan yeah
yeah thank you very much how could you
do it again sometime
alright